[Music]  for a castle straight out of a fairy  tale look no further than the alcázar of  Segovia located in central Spain the  alcázar of Segovia is one of the  country's most visited and distinctive  landmarks built in the 12th century the  Alcazar has served many functions over  the years a fortress a royal palace a  state prison an Artillery College and  most recently a museum and military  archive however its most famous function  could arguably be that it served as an  inspiration and some of the most iconic  Disney films the similarities between  Segovia and Cinderella can be found in  the building's brick facade turrets and  location perched high above the  neighbouring countryside Walt Disney  also went on to reproduce Segovia as the  Queen's castle and Snow White with it  appearing in the film in its almost  exact form if you can make it up more  than a hundred and fifty stairs to the  top of the tower you will be rewarded  with stunning views fit for a queen  [Music]  you